the first white house press conference
under the new administration happened
yesterday
there was one good question during the
whole press conference
and it's a very good question in fact
and i'm very happy was asked i'm a
little surprised
that because this is a question from a
reporter for ewtn i'm a little surprised
they got called on
but they made use of their time here it
is go ahead all the way in the back
yeah hi uh congratulations on your new
position uh owen jensen with ewtn global
catholic network
two big concerns for pro-life americans
the hyde amendment which of course
keeps tax payer dollars as you know from
paying for abortions medicaid abortions
and the mexico city policy which under
the previous administration
expanded to keep tax dollars from
overseas paying for abortions
so what are president what is president
biden planning on doing in those two
items right now
uh well i think we'll have more to say
on the mexico city policy in the coming
days
um but i will just take the opportunity
to
remind all of you that he is a devout
catholic and somebody who
attends church regularly he started his
day attending church with his family
this morning
but i don't have anything more okay
that was the strangest non-sequitur what
does it have to do with anything
you were asked about his what he's going
to do mexico city policy
height amendment very specific policy
questions
that's a good question from from that
reporter very from ewtn
and is the the answer is well he went to
chur he went to church this morning
that was the answer to the question of
are you going to force federal funding
of abortion
he went to church now
if if that answer means anything if it's
indicating anything
um it should be indicating that well of
course not of course he's not going to
force federal funding of abortion or
force forces to pay for abortions
overseas or anything like that
that's that's that's what it should mean
and i would appreciate it if that's what
it meant
you know if the question was is the
president going to force federal funding
of abortion
well what do you mean he goes to church
of course not what do you expect he's a
christian he's a real christian
but i'm i i suspect that's not the
implication of that answer
the implication is uh yeah he's gonna
he's radically pro-abortion we already
know that
he wants federal funding he wants to
increase funding of planned parenthood
and everything else
uh but you you can't criticize criticize
him for that
as a conservative christian because he's
a christian too
and so because a christian who's in a
position of power
supports this position that means
christians can support it that means
it's a valid position for christians to
hold
that's the logic and it is deranged
logic
it's not logic at all because that's
absolutely not true
and as a catholic you know
if you are a catholic and you
categorically reject
and deny the moral authority of the
catholic church
then you're not a catholic and so that's
how i can say that's how i can
that's how i i can sit here and actually
say
joe biden is not a catholic he says he's
a catholic he's
lying he's not one that is a lie
and yes i can say that because no i
don't i'm not peering inside his soul
i'm not reading his mind i don't need to
i'm listening to what he says
and i also know that being a catholic
means something
and one of the things that it means at a
minimum is that you accept the moral
authority of the church
if you don't you don't have to right
living in america you don't have to
accept the moral authority of the church
um and if you don't then okay you're not
a catholic you can be anything else
but if you are catholic that's what it
means joe biden categorically denies the
moral authority of the church
because the church has always been very
clear on this
for two thousand years and in fact it's
been very clear about killing babies
it is gravely immoral it is gravely
immoral mortally sinful to do
gravely immoral mortally sinful to
support to fund to promote
and you as a catholic you cannot say
i disagree and still remain a catholic
right that's that's a logical conclusion
in the same way that um
[Music]
you know i cannot say i'm
a mormon but i deny that joseph smith
was a prophet
like i i can't say that i can physically
say it
but in saying it i have denounced my
mormonism if i was mormon which i'm not
but
um if you claim to be part of a religion
but you reject the basic
tenets of that religion then you're not
part of that religion
say on the other end i can't say uh i'm
an atheist
but i believe in god well then you're
not an atheist
it's not like you're being ruled out of
atheism by some overarching
you know authority of atheism but it's
just that's a lot there's there's a
logical contradiction here right
so there's a logical contradiction in
saying that you're a catholic who
supports abortion
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated